apparently having a bowel obstruction is
a lot more dangerous than i thought it
would be
which should have been obvious because
if your bowels explode it doesn't end
well for you or anybody around you
uh also hi i am back home and i slept
for 12 hours after i got back from the
hospital
and i thought it would be a good idea to
post a video that bridged the gap
between me being
in bed at a hospital and then going back
to normal content which i feel would
have been a little
jarring at best um and this particular
trip to the hospital
because i've had a few now was uh
weird to say the least you know and it
was weird because
well probably for obvious reasons and
i'm not going to beat around the bush it
was the most crowded i've ever seen in
er
period there was so many people in there
every bed was packed
doctors were running around nurses were
running around everyone looked stressed
and haggard
and in a weird way when they came to me
and they saw that i had a
normal thing to deal with you know i
think they were relieved because it was
like something that wasn't covered
related and it seemed
seemingly normal and they were very nice
to me uh and they were just like
they're just like really really sweet in
the er especially the doctor who was
there was just like
really kind and understanding and i
almost felt bad because i was like i
wasn't sure if i was supposed to come in
anyway
because i didn't know if it was going to
be a problem but they said they were
glad i did and this is how i know
the bowel obstructions are extra
dangerous is because they said if i
waited
that's usually how people die from bowel
obstructions i wasn't in any danger of
dying because i came in way early it's
usually people that have these kinds of
pain for bowel obstructions and they
wait like a day or two days just to go
in
like if you've got some weird stomach
pain go see a doctor like it's
it's it's probably nothing but it could
also be your intestines exploding
also my my ng tube placement was very
interesting i'm not trying to call out
anyone you know because an ng tube is
not fun if you've ever had an ng tube it
is
not a pleasant experience what they do
is they shove
a a tube that's maybe about a quarter
inch thick
through your nose down the back of your
throat and into your stomach
and it's apparently for putting things
into your body and taking them out
when i was in the hospital this time
they did both but
the process by which is very very
painful and you know they'll dose you up
with morphine at first
but even so just having someone crack
the back of your sinuses to get this
tube back there
and then shove it down your throat is uh
not fun and for me it was especially not
fun because the first time that it went
down or the nurse tried to get it down
it went into my lungs
[Laughter]
let me tell you getting a lube
covered plastic tube shoved into your
lungs ain't
fun at all and and it was i i felt so
bad
for for the nurse i end up like i felt
bad for the nurse
like you know she shoves it down to my
throat and i'm just like
she pulls it out a little bit not all
the way so it's like still in my nose
and i'm like
i think that was in my lungs and she's
going like no
no way that was in your lungs and i'm
like listen lady i
i'm not gonna sue you or anything like
i'm just telling you i'm not an expert
at the inside of my lungs or how that
feels but that went in my lungs but
the trooper that i am is i'm like all
right let's do it again cause
last time i did this you know there's
the water drinking trick where you
usually just like
as it's going down you swallow water so
that it definitely can go down in the
stomach
this time we didn't do that i'm not 100
sure why i think it's just like they
didn't want me to add anything else to
my stomach
um but that being said every time
she shoved it down without water it was
just straight and
just like straight into my lungs every
single time i felt bad for them
very painful experience but at the end
of the day i'm just like you know
whatever it's what you got to do to get
it done
like the treatment is what it is you got
to suck out the food that i've eaten
so it doesn't explode my intestines i
get that and i'm like i'm prepared for
it
i've done it before i'm ready i forgot
how much
that sucks they had to pull it all the
way out because the third time i was
like
let's back up a step let's take a little
breather you know but then um
i said i said okay i'm ready and then we
went back down water drinking drink it
went right back down
but man you forget how bad an ng tube is
uh after it's been like five years that
sucks
it's not like it's the most painful
thing straight up it's just that it
never goes away
so like imagine you have something stuck
in your throat and you're trying to
swallow it down
but it's always there and it runs from
your throat all the way top to bottom
out your nose and then you've got this
thing in your nose that's constantly
constantly like rubbing in the back your
sinuses it's burning every time you
breathe
it's just it's just very unpleasant your
eyes are constantly the the
that is making this eye constantly like
water that's why in the video you saw me
i was just like crying out of this eye
it's not because i was sad it's just
because literally i had something shoved
in my sinuses so
eventually you'll get used to it like it
takes like a day of just like
oh i can't swallow oh i can't breathe
you know it's just that but
at the end of the day i'm just like look
whatever it takes to get done they were
great at the hospital you know i got to
give the biggest shout out in the world
to the teams that are working in
hospitals right now because
i can't imagine the stress i just can't
imagine the stress
i really really cannot and you know
there's normally
a lot of stress to deal with that job
but especially now
like healthcare workers they are going
through
hell absolute hell right now
like it was scary when i was in there
and i can't imagine going back to that
every single day
or however many days you work and going
into that
every day like just
god we got to do more for them you know
that's why i was always just like i
gotta be as nice as i can be because i
don't care what what kind of thing
they're gonna put me through like i'm
not gonna complain
once and i didn't like i'm not a
complainer so i didn't mind waiting for
tests i didn't mind anything like that
uh and and my waiting was thankfully
very entertaining
because i had next to me the most
complaining patient i've ever
experienced in my life
sounded like a sweet old lady straight
bad out of hell
you ask any nurse about a nightmare
patient and you can get an
idea of what this lady was all about
constantly
constantly ringing the nurse button like
made it so no one else on the floor
could get any help because she was just
constantly like
hello i need some help i need to go to
the
commode i need two people to lift me
if we can get more that'd be fine i was
like i don't know what this lady looked
like i like it seemed like she i didn't
know what was wrong with her i didn't
know what was happening to her
it was like she must have gotten into
some kind of pretzel folding machine
accident
or something like that she was twisted
up and couldn't move or anything but she
was also fragile as glass like i don't
know if anyone touched her she'd scream
and i get it like you're in the hospital
you're in pain you're here for some
reason obviously but i just was like
oh my god every five seconds and when
she came back from surgery it was
constant like just like i'm confused
i thought i was going to be in the
recovery room i'm supposed to be in the
recovery room it's like you were in the
recovery room now you're in your normal
room he's like no
i'm back in my normal room can you turn
my bed
can you turn the iv so i can see it drip
i
don't think it's working is it dripping
my arm feels
wet like just like i was trying to be as
nice as possible
the only thing i had to tell the nurses
was when i had a bowel movement
that was the only thing i had to tell
him so like i get to
in between her i get to ring the bell
and it's just like hey
good news this is mark from 828 here
i had a bow movement
god you know it was so weird having the
internet
celebrate me having a bowel movement i
can't believe i
just like i was i knew it was going to
be kind of like that but i had no idea
it was like you guys were going to make
a trend on twitter or something like
that
anyway like i could talk forever about
it but i won't but i'm back
i had a experience at the hospital but
you know my whole the whole staff there
was so sweet even even the poor lady
like i feel bad for her
that that was shoving the tube in my
lungs it's just like i didn't blame her
at all i don't blame her like it's not
an easy thing to do obviously she didn't
she hated doing it because she could see
how much pain it was causing me
but you know me i'm just like i can take
it my body can take it like it's okay
just don't shove it in my lungs like
that that'd be appreciated like if
if it's all right you know if it's not
procedure i'd like it not in my lungs
anyway i could go on forever about it
but i'm back home i seem to be good
uh i'm gonna take it easy for like a
week but that doesn't mean the videos
are gonna be taking it easy i'm still
going to be making videos
um but i'm on kind of like a soft liquid
food diet for at least a week now
to make sure everything goes away and if
it does come back then i'll probably
need surgery but i'm hoping that i won't
because obviously that would be
unpleasant i'd rather not do that and it
put me out of commission for a while
so i'm back videos will resume thank you
everybody so much for watching
uh there'll be a follow-up video pretty
soon about how i'm an [ __ ] but that's
a story for another day
so well you'll see that one that's
coming next
but right now i'm fine so thank you
everybody so much for caring and thank
you for all the well wishes and thank
you for all the memes
god the memes from my this hospital trip
are funnier than anything i've seen
in a long time just really funny memes
really you guys are so [ __ ] funny
sometimes anyway i gotta go
so i'll see you around bye